so you've got to see this stuff that
there's a growing trend which we
expected for reporters to ask joe white
joe biden's white house press secretary
jen
sackey tough questions during press
briefings that are aren't actually tough
questions
they're just sort of fake drama and
attack lines
and i'm the first person to tell you
that
every press secretary regardless of
party
should get tough questions real tough
questions
questions like joe biden promised two
thousand dollar checks right away
and we're three weeks in and talking
about fourteen hundred dollars
explain that's a real question of uh
urgent importance to the american people
but what i'm gonna play for you today
and what we've seen
in the press briefing room for two and a
half weeks now under joe biden's
presidency
these aren't real tough questions these
are ridiculous questions so let's check
out some of these examples here is a
reporter asking
why won't joe biden call antifa
terrorists what are the definitions of
terrorists
and why is the focus only on january 6th
that
there was jake sullivan mentioned the
focus on domestic terrorism yesterday
for this administration
i think a lot of people want to know how
does this administration define
the term domestic terrorist in what way
well it does that include
antifa specifically what how
do you set those parameters for domestic
terrorists especially as we see
you know a lot of focus on the january 6
maybe not as
much focus on some of the extremism and
violence in
the north the northwest well uh i've
answered a version of this question a
couple times before but i know
everybody's not in the briefing room
every day
uh the reason we have the review which
is not a political review
but is a review done by our national
security team something tasked
again to take a review of domestic
violent extremism
we'll cover uh uh incidents uh across
the board
you sort of get the sense that gen saki
deals with this the way a parent deals
with an obstinate kid throwing a tantrum
sort of like
some amused detachment but still having
to
remain strict in order to control the
situation and not encourage bad behavior
and then a question that sort of tries
to paint teachers as these
stubborn adversaries refusing to go back
to school
and gensaki does a good job of not
letting the framing be
that teachers are bad and the enemy and
are going gonna have to be forced
back those questions but go ahead will
president biden
use the power of the bully pulpit to
help cajole teachers
who are unwilling to go back to schools
to go back
well one i'm just going to reject the
premise of the question
i will say i have teachers in my family
as i'm sure many of you do they are the
first people to tell you
that being teaching in the classroom and
being able to engage with kids in the
classroom or
middle schoolers or high schoolers in
the classroom it makes their job more
enjoyable
makes them more effective at what they
do so she turns the question around
and it doesn't matter the reporter keeps
going and then tries to
incorrectly inaccurately summarize what
gensake actually said
that sounded like a yes with an asterisk
i i
you if you are the spokesperson for the
white house you could certainly say that
but you are not but you can ask me
another question
my second quick question uh is uh last
year
these briefings are there's there's an
attempt to turn these briefings into a
joke
but for very different reasons than they
were a joke under trump's white house
press secretary kaylee mcinanny
another game that they're playing is
saying you know biden said unity
biden promised bipartisanship but
no republicans are supporting the
coveted bill so
is this evidence that joe biden is
abandoning bipartisanship and unity
and jen sackey is receiving this
question all the time and she's doing a
good job answering
and given the president's remarks
earlier in his change of tone it does
seem that he is now okay if this does
happen just with democratic support
despite those hopes
and despite his calls for unity well
first of all the president
ran on the um on unifying the country
and putting forward ideas that would
help address the crises were
facing he didn't run on a promise to
unite the democratic and republican
party into one party in washington
this package has the vast majority of
support from the american public
i'm fine with the question and she
should keep answering it this way but it
needs to be said really clearly
joe biden made a proposal and then met
with republicans to hear their side
to get their thoughts to get a sense of
what they want
republicans proposed something absurd
they proposed a package
less than one-third the size of what
democrats and joe biden want
and what joe biden and democrats want is
popular with the american people
joe biden has a 69 approval rating on
covid
63 approval overall you don't get that
with just democrats
trump never even got to 50 approval on
one day of his presidency
and joe biden's already at 63 overall 69
on covet
you can lead a horse to water but you
can't make them drink
joe biden engaged with republicans the
american people want something
else democrats want something else and
joe biden wants something else and it's
joe biden's responsibility to get it
done
at some point you can't keep waiting
around for bad
faith actors so i guess this
is sort of how it's going to be i would
prefer
rather than silly non-gotchas
that they actually put together some
serious well-calibrated tough questions
that's what i would like to see
it's not clear that that's actually
going to happen
and uh as we saw uh very early on
in joe biden's presidency it's not clear
that you know the as she points out
unity and bipartisanship don't mean
you have to give up everything to get a
republican to vote with you
when you have the country more behind
you and more behind these ideas than
they ever were behind anything donald
trump did
uh at some point you have to just say
listen we i i offered everything we
offered the meetings we offer
what they want is ridiculous we're not
going to do it it's not what the
american people want
at a certain point you have to do that
it's your responsibility and i hope that
that's actually what joe biden is doing
now
one of our sponsors is four sigmatic the
company
best known for their delicious mushroom
coffee
four sigmatics mushroom coffee is
organic
fair trade single origin arabica coffee
with both lion's mane and chaga
mushrooms chaga mushrooms have actually
been shown to have potential in
supporting the immune system
in peer-reviewed studies i've been
drinking
four sigmatic coffee a lot lately it
actually doesn't taste anything like
mushrooms it just tastes like any
delicious coffee but it's really easy on
my stomach doesn't give me any jittery
feeling or a midday crash
and they have over 20 000 5 star
reviews and best of all if you don't
love it
you'll get 100 percent of your money
back because
they stand behind their product you've
got nothing to lose by giving it a try
four sigmatic is giving my audience up
to 40 percent off
and free shipping when you go to
4sigmatic.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video